the white house being accused of
screening reporters questions ahead of
press briefings
according to a new report the biden
press team quote on occasion probe
reporters
to see what questions they plan on
asking new white house press secretary
jen saki
when called upon during briefings end
quote press secretary saki was not asked
about it today at her press briefing
but the white house did say earlier it
regularly engages with reporters who
will be in the briefings
so it can provide as much information as
possible
well we've got a professional a former
press secretary on this panel miss dana
perino
so dana do you think it's uh jen saki
and the white house press team
uh pursuing a legitimate avenue to say
hey what do you guys want to know about
so we can be prepared well i i wish you
had been asked about it at the briefing
because i think she would have answered
it very well
um now i don't i didn't see the
communications between
the white house press office and the
reporters that complained
apparently serious enough concerns that
they raised it up to the white house
communications
agency or association whatever they call
themselves correspondents association
um but here's what i know um it's
really good practice to have your
deputies and your assistant press
secretaries
have their ears to the ground to be
reading what the reporters are
interested in
so that you can make sure that you can
be informative when you get to the
briefing i mean
twitter's been making fun of jen saki
for a week because she
says i'll circle back with you which is
another way of saying i'll get back to
you whichever way
but you know if you don't want to say
circle back it'd be a good idea to find
out
what's on their minds now i think a
couple of things have happened one i
think
coveted restrictions in the white house
are really tough right now
because reporters typically they can
just wall sign up into the press
secretary's office or the deputy's
office
and let us know like what's on your mind
what are you thinking about okay fine
interesting okay see you later i would
never ask for a specific question and i
would never
not call on somebody who told me they
were going to ask about something
but right now because of kovid you can't
do that and there used to be a thing
called the gaggle which was an earlier
morning
get-together more informal wasn't on
camera usually
and that would give you a sense of what
the reporters were thinking about i
called it a recon mission
uh so i think that there's a little bit
of a miscommunication i wish she would
have been asked about it today because i
think she could have handled it well
so jesse in fact uh when i was a white
house reporter i think there were
gaggles and
you know the press secretaries would
even it was when you had a presidential
press conference they would alert the
president as to which reporter was
likely to ask about which topic so
why is this a controversial what do you
think
i'm torn because i like the story
because it confirms my bias
but i hate the fact that the daily beast
broke it
and i don't trust them so i don't know
how to process this
but the department of justice just
appointed the business associate of the
lawyer representing hunter biden
why hasn't that been asked about i mean
biden killed
10 000 pipeline jobs on his first week
it seems like a good question i mean why
haven't they asked if joe knows tony b
we have still not gotten the answer to
the fact that joe biden
shared an office with the money man for
the chinese communist energy billionaire
shared an office with guy named dong and
and we don't get
questions like that we don't get
questions like his executive orders on
immigration
have been thrown in the dumpster by a
federal
judge or the fact that
his energies are said oh yeah go build
solar panels
it just seems to me i don't know juan
have you noticed a change in tone
in the white house press briefing room i
i just can't put my
finger on it but it seems to me that the
reporters
i get your support agree with everything
joe's doing
oh okay katie uh you had you're capable
asking very tough questions but uh we
see sake holding
daily briefings getting back circling
back to reporters do you think she's
doing a good job
i think she could be better prepared and
i do think that this is an effort by her
team to get her
more information about what reporters
are interested in asking about but i
think
this is a great opportunity to send
waters world
to the white house briefing to ask some
of the questions that jessie has
jen all right over here
and greg we talk about that change uh
there's no press is the enemy of the
people there's no cancel culture attacks
on reporters
do you think they're doing a better job
more discipline in this white house
they're not even working anymore let's
face it
i mean the good i mean at least trump
went up there engaged with them and it
was
interesting and they were on their toes
the sad thing is is that she's prepped
and she's still
not doing very good uh but i'm with
jesse on this one i don't trust anything
that comes out of the daily beast
so who knows i will say this this was
this might have been going on for a long
time but not reported on which is kind
of interesting because the reporters
didn't want to say anything because they
were
the beneficiary and it probably was some
somebody that was pissed off
but but then jesse's right it's like
what about the why are there so many
things that are not asked
do you notice that they're not asking
about joe's plans with north korea
maybe it's because he doesn't need to
make up a plan because trump solved that
maybe he can unsolve
the north korea success story with an
executive action
how about that all righty
one more thing up next for you